- Hello, and welcome to Ed
Talks with Khan Academy.
I'm Kristen DiCerbo,
the chief learning officer
here at Khan Academy.
And I'm excited today
to talk to Ned Johnson.
Who's an author, speaker,
and founder of PrepMatters,
which is a company
providing academic tutoring,
educational planning, and
standardized test prep.
We're gonna talk today
about lots of topics,
including anxiety and test anxiety.
So if you are interested in learning more
about how we can reduce
the stress in our lives,
in our learners lives, stay tuned.
Before we get started, I
want to remind everyone
that at Khan Academy, we are a nonprofit,
and if you go to khanacademy.org/donate,
you can give to help us
continue to complete our mission
and to work towards providing
a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere.
Also want to thank our corporate sponsors
who have stepped up in the time of COVID,
including AT&T, general
motors, and fastly.
If you have ran to relisten
to this discussion,
or find other discussions between myself,
Sal and other folks in the ed tech space
and the education sphere,
you can join Homeroom
with Sal, it's a podcast,
and get audio versions
wherever you get your podcasts.
So take a look out for that.
As I said, I'm excited to
talk to Ned Johnson today.
He has written three books.
The one that I first learned about was
"The Self-Driven Child"
and we'll be also talking
about his most recent book,
"What Do You Say?
How to Talk with Kids to Build Motivation,
Stress Tolerance, and a Happy Home."
So looking forward to our discussion.
Hi, Ned, welcome.
- Thank you for having me.
I'm so, so thrilled to talk
through this with you to,
and of course, like anyone in education,
big fan of the great work
that the Khan Academy does in helping kids
all over the place, so thanks for having.
- Oh, thank you.
Absolutely.
I'd like to start
discussions by asking people,
what was your journey?
How did you come to work in this field
of test preparation and education?
- Well, honestly,
I graduated college
without a really clear plan
of what I was gonna do.
And I followed a friend to the DC
and I took a job with a
local test prep company
who said they were looking for folks
who are good at standardized tests
and like working with
high school students.
And I'd always been pretty
good at standardized tests.
And at that point, was pretty
nearly a high school student.
And I thought, well, gosh,
I can give this a try.
And I just, I really fell in love
with talking with teenagers.
I just, it's such, Paul
Tuff in his wonderful book,
"The Years That Matter Most,"
now "The Inequality Machine,"
talks about the first year of college,
but I think it also applies
to last year of high school
of sort of the uncertainty
when he describes
the belonging uncertainty.
And so during those transitions,
kids are vulnerable.
They're vulnerable to stress,
but they're also vulnerable
to new ideas about themselves,
and there's just something
really cool for me, at least,
about working one-on-one with kids.
And I'm not mom and dad,
I'm not asking them to clean the room,
I'm not a teacher giving grades.
I'm just all about what
trying to help them
in all the ways that
are meaningful to them.
So I've been,
I think something like 50,000 hours,
one-on-one talking with kids-
- Oh my gosh.
- since the early 90s and
it's just, it never gets old.
It's really cool.
- That is fantastic.
So you write and talk a lot about stress.
Let's start there.
- I do.
- Is all stress bad?
Are there should be thinking-
- No.
- about stress in different
ways at different times?
- So yeah, so first of
all, all stress is not bad.
Classically, when we talk about stress,
there's something called
the Yerkes-Dodson curve,
which some of your
educators may know about it.
It's a bell curve, it's
a performance curve.
And it's really measured
in physiological arousal.
So kind of what are those stress hormones?
What are the neurotransmitters
that are running through
our bodies and brains?
And if we have no stress,
typically there's not much
by way of performance.
If you play against a
team who's just terrible,
you're gonna win, but you're
not gonna play your best.
At some point, you start
to feel butterflies, right?
Before a big game, before big math test,
you're trying to talk to somebody
who thinks you're really cute.
You should feel that
because it means that
you're paying attention.
It means that your primed for action.
It means that you're ready.
The challenges that more
isn't necessarily better,
and so at some point, ah,
then the performance starts to fall apart.
And so, what we're trying to talk about
is what helps any of us,
but especially kids,
feel like their place of what's
known as optimal arousal.
You're amped up enough to be excited,
but not so much that you
kind of lose your mind.
- That makes sense, it aligns to,
I've also read some about the impact
of stress hormones on memory
and that a low, some
level of stress hormones
can actually help you remember more,
but then it gets too high
and then you lose that.
- Well, yeah, and especially, you know,
one of the things that,
so my coauthor, William Stixrud,
he's a clinical neuropsychologist.
So he often works with kids
where things aren't going well,
you know, learning isn't easy,
attention isn't easy,
maybe emotional regulation isn't easy.
And both for him as a neuropsychologist,
and me as a test prep geek,
we would submit the most
important outcome of high schools
not where you go to college.
And I don't know, all
my clients are good one,
but seriously, it's developing the brain
that kids are gonna carry into college
and then to adulthood.
And cortisol, the dominant stress hormone,
again, we need enough of it
to kind of get us out
of bed in the morning,
but too much it erodes the hippocampus,
the major memory center of the brain,
it weakens the connection
between the prefrontal cortex,
you know, the kind of
thinking part of our brain
and the amygdala,
and if you're too tired and
too stressed for too long,
very bad things happen
to developing brains.
And we just don't wanna see young people,
particularly teenagers, who
really sculpting the brains
that will carry into adulthood.
And we just don't wanna see
them be stressed all the time.
Find to have intense in
you, work hard, relax hard,
work hard, relax hard.
That's kind of, just like working out,
that's how you get stronger,
and we want kids to have that experience.
But if they're constant
like this all the time,
just not good for developing brains,
or for test performance for that matter.
- Right, right.
So what are signs that
someone who's too stressed
and those stress levels are too high?
- Oh, golly.
I mean, there are all sorts of symptoms
when you talk about diagnosed anxiety.
I mean, it's the words they're using,
it's the constant fretfulness,
it's perfectionism run them up,
it's difficulty sleeping,
it's difficult with appetite,
you know, with depression.
I mean, I'm not a clinical psychologist,
but if you really have a kid
who you're worried about mental health,
just go to some of the websites
that we'll talk about these things,
but classically,
but assuming that's just
garden variety anxiety, right?
Which we all experience to a degree,
but I really have become an interested in,
for years kind of what I
think it was underperformance.
So when I first started doing test prep,
again I was always pretty
good at these tests,
I was trained really well on
how to talk about these tests,
but I kept having the experience
of really bright kids
from their great families,
their great schools,
they did all the hard work,
and they go and take
the test and go, bush.
And typically, I'd get an irate
phone call from the parents,
I don't understand, (speaking gibberish)
I didn't know anything when
I was 23, 24 doing this,
but I was fortunate enough
the parents would send their kids back
and we'd have another conversation.
And so, I'd asked them, you know,
did the proctor give up the time?
Was the kid next to you to distract?
What it looked like?
And almost always the
conversation would end
with something like,
I don't know,
there was so much more than
what we did for practice.
And so, oh, okay, that makes sense.
Oh, wait, wait a second,
wait, wait, wait, wait,
for all the reasons that
people may not like the SAT,
or may not like the ACT,
that just don't like
standardized tests generally,
you have to give them
this, they're standardized.
So the idea, right,
that this test that they took
was so fundamentally different
than what they'd done for
the books of practice tests,
just didn't make a lot of sense.
So I went to go and take the SAT
at a local public high school,
and I'm 25, 26, you know,
I was probably five years into
being the test post late 20s.
So I'm sitting there
with all these teenagers
and kind of eavesdropping,
I'm like, what's going
through their heads?
And are they nervous or anxious, whatever.
And this is that I wrote
a book years ago about,
and Khan called "Conquering the SAT"
about anxiety and test performance.
And for no particular reason,
I checked my own pulse.
It's 100, it was 140 beats a minute,
140 beats a minutes-
- Oh my gosh.
- which is like running up
and down stairs 15 times.
And I thought, this is curious
'cause I didn't think that I was nervous
and I have very few identifiable skills,
but one of them
is that I've always been
good at standardized tests.
So like, and I didn't need it
'cause I wasn't going back to college,
like what was going on?
And so a lot of times kids
will be super all prepared
and then bomb in math test or the SAT
or whatever it happens to be.
And we look around and assume,
well, you didn't study hard enough, right,
or maybe you're just not that good,
you're not as smart as
you thought you were.
That's a thought that helps nobody, right?
The tutor is no good.
The program is no good.
And those are all things
that we might wanna consider.
But in some ways, if we
take seriously the fact
that test anxiety is
rooted in neurochemistry,
it doesn't, part of what
we worked to put hard
and worked hard to put into kids' brains,
that if under too much
pressure or perceived stress,
they lose their minds,
then it all goes for nothing.
So I would say when things are unexpected
is the way that I would
look for anxiety, right?
If a kid is really, you know,
is taken this seriously,
we have sense that they
demonstrate the abilities
in other ways,
and does class discussion
or essays or whatever,
how do they perform when
there isn't pressure
versus how they perform
when there is pressure.
And if there's a big disconnect there.
Then we start thinking about
how do we get more comfortable
with that perceived pressure
or find ways to adapt
to kind of ratchet down
the perceived pressure of that activity.
- That makes sense.
Yeah, thinking about that
unexpected performance
that doesn't align with what you see
and other kinds of settings
and other kinds of ways
that they've demonstrated what they now.
All right, so how do we
help them ratchet that down?
What does that look like?
- Well, there's one place to start.
There's wonderful research
by a woman named Sonia Lupien
who said, it's the Centre
for Studies of Human Stress.
I think I got that right
in Montreal, Canada.
And she has a beautiful acronym
of what makes people nuts, okay?
So N.U.T.S, N-U-T-S.
So N is novelty, so new situation.
So, hey, it's not just the coronavirus
'cause it's the novel coronavirus, right?
If you're taking a test and you're like,
I've never seen that before,
it's never a happy thing
like if you're shopping.
You as unpredictability,
so for the work that I
do in standardized tests,
you know, am I gonna
have enough time or not,
if you know that you won't
have time to do three questions
no matter what you do,
well, that's great to know.
Then we figure out
which three questions do
we just not do, right?
We just fill in those answers.
T is perceived threat.
And so, pre-COVID for most kids,
and for most of us in
particularly for kids in school,
that's threat to ego.
Am I gonna look stupid?
Or people that think I'm an idiot.
Do am I gonna think of my parents,
gonna think of my teacher's gonna think.
And then S is a low sense of control.
And it turns out this is what
the book of Will and I wrote
in "The Self-Driven Child" is
that a low sense of control
is the most stressful thing
that people can experience.
And so novelty, unpredictably,
the three, you know,
this is one of the great
things about the Khan Academy
is you can have a great teacher, awesome,
and never need to spend
your time with Khan,
or you could have a teacher,
you've had three teachers
in chemistry this year
because, well, COVID, right?
And you could feel like I'm responsible
for doing well in this,
but I have no way to learn this.
Oh, oh, that's really stressful.
If you know that there's a tool,
it's not, gosh, you'd rather learn this
at 10 o'clock in the morning
with a wonderful teacher,
but that's not where we are right now.
So if we think about in a given situation,
how much of it is the novelty?
How much is it that you feel threatened?
How much of it that low sense of control?
And we tack those things in turn.
I can talk very credibly
about the values that you
can't find a standardized test,
but I can also talk until
I'm blue in the face
about all the ways that
the SAT is a terrible test
and they're a bunch of ragamuffins.
And I do that with kids
to decrease the stress
that they feel about,
say, look, you may need to take this test
for the college that you're applying to,
but let's disabuse ourselves of the idea
that this is measuring something innate,
like your intelligence,
because, golly, for most kids,
that makes them super, super anxious.
So that's kind of the first thing
is we wanna try to diagnose
what's going on, right?
I mean, a lot of kids I work with,
they have an older sibling, right?
Sorry, sorry, your sister's
an incredible person,
but she did you no favors
by getting a 1590 on the SAT
and rolling off tonight at school.
That's kind of intense, right?
And so, this is something
that parents can do
that the teachers can do.
And you try to figure out
where, Tina Payne Bryson,
if you know coauthor of
"The Whole-Brain child"
and a lot of other great books,
talks about stress is what we perceive
when there's a gap between the perceived,
what's being required of us
and what we think we're able to do.
And so we may wanna decrease
the demands on a person
or increase the support.
Now, there's some really fun research,
and it's just hard for parents there,
when they ask parents
kind of what their
expectations are of their kids?
And then they also ask them, you know,
and how much do you think
they can actually meet those expectations?
The wider the gap the worst things get.
And I just spent a lot
of time with parents
trying to talk them down, for now,
these expectations that you
have to go to Princeton,
I love orange, but really
four years of orange.
I mean, it's not the only
place in the world to go,
but it's complicated.
Kids are complicated.
Parenting is complicated.
But that will be the first
place that I would start.
I mean, we talk about a lot.
I spent the amount of
money that I've been paid
to talk with kids about sleep,
that I have not been paid to be talking
about sleep deprivation.
I've been paid to help them, you know,
prepare for these tests.
But I can talk for hours
about what sleep
deprivation does to brains,
one, to developing brains,
but two, from a performance,
just for folks who don't know.
I mentioned a little while ago,
cortisol was the dominant stress hormone.
When we're sleep deprived,
the amygdala, the stress reactions,
about 60% more reactive,
and our body's just pumping out cortisol.
And so we're stressed all the time.
There's a kid I was
working with years ago,
I met her in Princeton,
she had an older brother
who went to Princeton
who was a baseball player.
She was super academic,
but found test harder part
because she was just
more stressed more easily
than, you know, maybe her brother was.
So we're doing the ACT
and she has taken this
test far too many times.
And we're meeting on a Sunday,
she's taking a test
the following Saturday.
We're doing all the last room interview
I think she's an academic
kid, great family.
And I finally say, and reminder that,
if you can be in bed by 10 or 10:30,
you're gonna do so much
better on the test,
well, then I'm in the middle
of this and her face hauls.
And I'm like, "What?"
And she said, "Well, my friends."
And her friends were great
and they're super important to her.
She's a 17 year old girl, I get that.
I said, "I understand that, I understand."
"But for one week, could we
maybe just like, you know,
just hanging up with
the phone in the kitchen
to go to bed early?"
"Maybe."
"So what if your mom
paid you to go to bed?"
She's like, "My mom wouldn't pay me."
I'm like, "what if I paid you?"
She's like, "what?"
And I said, "But I don't trust you.
So your mom's in charge.
You have to hand your phone
to your mama at 10 o'clock.
And if you're in bed and lights out,
I'll give you 20 bucks."
And she said, "For the week?"
I said, "I'll give you $20 every night."
She said, "No, you won't."
I said, "Yes, I will."
She said, "No," I said, "Watch me."
She shows up on Friday, we
have one last more to do,
and I hand her five $20 bills.
Now this is wealth redistribution
is really a parent's money.
And she goes off and gets the test.
I mean, and she had always been capable
that she could have probably
done this months ago
if she could have been less stressed.
So sleep deprivation is a big deal.
There's a wonderful book,
I'll hold this up called "Choke."
It's the provocative
title if you know this.
This is Sian Beilock.
She's now the president
of Barnard College.
She is incredible.
Love, love, love her work.
And she looks at
underperformance public speaking,
athletic standardized tests.
And one of her models is the idea
of having the mindset of a predator
rather than a prey,
because the prefrontal cortex,
decision-making, planning,
problem solving, and
emotional mental flexibility,
all executive functions
of the prefrontal cortex,
the amygdala, the freeze,
fight, or flight response.
You don't wanna freeze,
you can't run away,
and there's nobody to invite
right in the middle of a test.
So we really don't want that
part of our brain going off.
And she says, "If you lean in with,"
what she describes, "this is
kind of having more swagger,
it can help you perform better."
So I actually did it.
I did a TikTok thing in the day to shoot
and now I know, old people
on TikTok, but whatever.
And so, I stumbled on
this great research at NIH
that found this of executive functions,
we know that stress really
messes with executive functions,
being anxious, bad, bad, bad,
but you know what doesn't?
Being angry.
So if you're worried about the SAT
or your math test, whatever,
I feel like, oh, ragamuffins, I hate them.
(speaking gibberish)
You're better often mad angry.
Then you are being anxious
'cause you'll actually think better.
So there's that.
- So interesting.
- You have more questions?
I have another one I'll
talk about in a minute,
but please jump in.
- Yeah, no, that was great.
So you talked about
lowering that, you know,
lowering the threshold.
When we think about teachers,
we have a question that came
in thinking about from Aviv,
what are the actions teachers can take
to help their students prepare
for that stress of assessment?
So even if we're not talking SAT,
we could be talking classroom assessments-
- That's the great part.
- like are there other things
that teachers can do.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean, there's several things.
I mean, first of all,
there's a wonderful
study that when students,
I think they were taking
a GRE, I can't remember,
but this of course applies to all tests,
when kids were as test-takers reminded
that some anxiety, back
to that bell curve,
actually improves their
performance, right?
That actually, you wanna have
some butterflies before the test.
That actually helps you focus.
That improve their performance
because then they weren't
worried about being worried.
They felt what they're
feeling physiologically.
They felt as this is me
preparing to go do battle, right?
That's super helpful.
The same Sonia Lupien of the N.U.T.S.,
one of the things that she talks about,
this incredibly useful tool
that like probably the single
best tool to lower stress
is plan B thinking.
I am so happy for test optional,
I can't even tell you,
because it lowers the stress.
You know, of course you
would love to get a 1500
because who wouldn't?
And I applied it to
Princeton, fantastic, right?
'Cause you look great in orange, I'm sure.
But goodness knows, you know,
if you don't get a 1500,
well, know what should we do?
You can still apply to
Princeton, you know?
And you know what happens if
you don't go to Princeton?
There are like 3,500 colleges
where you can also get, you know.
And so, in order to talk
about that plan B thinking,
a teacher really needs to have
a good relationship with the kid.
Less the kid feel like
you're trying to say,
you saying I can't do this.
Not what I'm saying at all.
I'm saying that it will
help you if, right?
From a stress perspective,
Bill and I in "The Self-Driven Child,"
we talk about the chapter in the book
called the non-anxious presence.
And I wish we'd made this up
'cause it's such a good term.
We borrowed this from a
guy named Edward Freeman
who's a rabbi.
He was a consultant.
He worked with schools and searchers
and synagogues and families.
And he simply made the point
that things work better
when the person or people in
charge aren't overly emotional,
aren't over-reactive.
And because stress is contagious,
but the good news is this,
all emotions are contagious.
Calm is contagious,
we discovered this when calm is contagious
is a mantra of the Navy seals.
So if your kids come to you
and they're super spun up, right?
If you can say, you know, Eli Lebowitz,
a professor of anxiety of
what's called the SPACE,
but we'll go into it,
and yeah, Eli talks about
making supportive statements.
And supportive statements
are simply saying,
yeah, I get that this
is really hard for you.
I can see that you're pretty
stressed out about this.
And I have every confidence
that you can deal with this.
I'm confident you can handle this.
And I'll help you in any way that I can.
Because so often we try
to say, "Oh my gosh,
it's not such a big deal, Kris,
it's just, oh my gosh."
And you're three hours
from that who even care?
Well, I'm trying to help you,
but I'm really invalidating
what you're feeling.
And you're feeling what you're
feeling for whatever reason.
But we also say,
I have every confidence that
this is gonna work on it.
If it just worked out just the
way you want, we can do this.
And I bet you can do this.
And you're gonna figure out
a way to make this work,
even if it's a plan B.
So in our new book "What Do You Say?"
We have a lot of scripts,
there are a lot of language
because it's hard as a teacher
when kids come at you with things
and they're super spun up and
your head, you're thinking,
oh my goodness, oh, wait,
wait, wait, time out.
We could be seeing this differently.
But what we're really trying
to do is get, thank you.
Yeah, that's the book.
Will Stixurd, genius.
What we're really trying
to do is get buy-in
in order to have kids
be open to our messages,
we really just start with
empathy and validation.
It makes sense to me
that you're pretty stressed out about this
as it feels like a big deal.
It makes sense to me.
I can get that you're pretty,
feel pretty intense about
this test having right now,
because there's some hard stuff on that,
but I'm confident that
you can handle this.
So, you know,
I don't wanna put one more thing
on the backs of teachers who are,
it feels like they're shouldering
the weight of the world right now.
But I will say that if
there's any single thing
that is valuable to
young people right now,
it's having a close connection
to one or more adults.
If there's a silver bullet
against the effects of
stress and developing brains,
it's feeling close connection to an adult,
ideally that's parents.
When we were writing this book,
we were meeting with all
these kids and we asked them,
who do you feel closest to in the world?
Sometimes with mom, sometimes with dad,
but sometime with grandma,
my aunt, my uncle,
sometimes the teacher.
I'm sitting in right now in Washington DC
and right across the street
from us is Wilson High School,
it's kind of the big public
high school in Northwest,
terrific school, great learners.
And we're working with,
we were talking with a bunch
of this kids, and this one,
and so, in the follow-up
question, we said,
"What about those people
makes you feel close to them?"
And there are two things.
One, they listened to me without judging.
And two, they don't tell
me what to do all the time.
So this boy went on to talk
about this biology teacher
who was just like this
fountain of wisdom and calm.
She wasn't his teacher,
she wasn't his teacher.
She'd never had him as a teacher.
He never had her as a teacher, excuse me.
But she was just known as the person
and all these kids
would just come in there
and they would just have lunch with her.
And she just asked them about their stuff.
And I'm sure they told
her some crazy stuff.
And, Lily, just being a
person where you can go,
"Oh, that's interesting
tell me more about that."
Because it's incredibly
valuable for lowering stress
and for developing motivation.
We can talk about motivation if you want,
but I'm an enormous fan of what's called,
we are known as fans,
of what's known as
self-determination theory.
And it's a model for intrinsic motivation,
you probably, I know
you know all about this.
- Yes, go ahead and explain
it I'm a big fan too.
- But the idea that, you know,
so often we think, you know,
parents, teachers, school
systems, politicians,
"We've got to get kids to work hard."
Well, from my perspective,
I have zero interest in kids working hard.
I have interest in they're
wanting to work hard
because extrinsic motivation
of fear or bribes,
they work for a while,
but it's a terrible way
to grow up with a brain,
simply trying to meet other
people's expectations of you.
What we really want is
kids to do the work, right?
Jess Lahey, you know "The Gift of Failure"
and people I know, love her work.
I saw how she talked with a
bunch of teachers and ask them,
and this one teacher said,
"You know what the three
R's of teaching are?
Relationships, relationships,
relationships."
And so, good teachers are
worth their week in gold
'cause they don't get kids to work hard.
They get kids to want to work hard.
Like whenever I meet with kids,
the first day is trying to
understand them as a learner,
like what's your favorite class?
Which your least favorite class?
Oh, you love math.
Is that the class, or is that the teacher?
And as you can imagine,
more than half the time it's,
"Oh, you know, it's pretty good,
but, oh, Ms. Rodriguez,
she's just, I don't know,
she makes it so interesting."
And part of that is that she
makes the math interesting,
but that she's interested in them, right?
And so, again, I just, you know,
I wish teachers have more autonomy.
I wish they had less on their
plates so that they just,
it was easier for them to
put as much time and energy
as they wanted to there
in the relationships
'cause for anyone who's an old
for like when you think back
about the class that you love most,
I can remember,
yeah, you can remember so
little of what we learned,
but I can remember Mr. Roberman
and just how much I love this
guy as a history teacher,
I took zero history in college,
but I loved him as a teacher, right?
And that's what great teachers do, right?
- Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
Let's take one more question
from YouTube the handle,
Math With TJA says,
"How do I clear my mind
after a big failure?"
So you can imagine you failed at something
or that's causes a lot of stress.
How do you get over that, and go for that,
you know, what the next
steps are gonna be?
- Well, gosh, I mean, one thing there's,
Lisa DiMora, if you know, I
love all these people and she's.
- She's a previous Ed Talk's guest.
- Oh, I just love her, you know.
And she makes the point that mental health
is the right feeling
for the right situation.
So if you really worked hard at a test
and you feel like you bombed it,
you're allowed to be upset, right?
You shouldn't be saying,
I shouldn't be upset.
Look, you're allowed to be pissed.
Like, gosh, darn it, I
really worked hard in that.
But we then have to move on, right?
What the real challenge
is when people get locked in rumination,
they beat themselves
and beat themselves up,
and beat themselves up.
And what we wanna try to do is
if you go back to that plan B thinking,
what else can I do?
Now the reality is, I love this,
this is a success coach
I follow in the 80s
who made the point that unexpected success
and unexpected failures,
those are what provide the source material
for great insights on your own life.
So it's worth trying what
happened there, right?
So talk to your math teacher,
talk to your friends,
compare notes, reflect.
Was I really well-prepared?
Was I well rested?
What was going on?
What was my subjective state?
What did it feel like going in there?
I mean, I feel that the
kids every year in school,
and I don't know what
grade the student is in,
we should have to work hard
and we shouldn't reengineer
ourselves learning,
because if you're not having to do things
more or differently,
in 11th grade that you did in 7th grade,
like, boy, a lot of people's time
is being wasted here, right?
There's a wonderful, wonderful,
wonderful book called,
"Make It Stick."
It's Henry Roediger the
third and a bunch of people.
If there's a, if you send
them notes afterwards,
he has, they have, they, I
forget the other authors.
I just know his name,
Michael Brown I think,
David Brown, something like that.
They have a fantastic
piece in psychology today
with basically the six
takeaways from "Make It Stick."
And it's things that you
have know all the stuff,
but it's spaced learning.
It's sleep.
It's the testing effect, right?
So retrieval practice.
So we don't just look at our notes,
we actually kind of test ourselves.
There's a lot of great stuff there.
And so it's worth,
when I think about
underperformance on tests,
math tests, SAT and that kind of thing.
I try to think about,
was it the input or was it the output?
Meaning did I test myself in ways
that I know that I really learned it?
And if I, because if I
just think I knew it,
it might've been a little trick
my brain was playing on me,
in which case I wanna examine
how it is that I'm learning?
Was I just cramming it?
But if I really knew the stuff
and I ended up performing,
well, then it's a
performance piece, right?
So we're back to, you know,
what blows up cortisol?
What helps you get your swagger on, right?
What gets you like Hulk smash mode?
When we take the test, right?
Listening to music.
I'm a huge, the number of students
to whom I have prescribed
the seven-minute workout.
Sonia, people don't know this,
it's 7, it's 12, 30-second exercise
that you can do anywhere you need,
no exercise equipment at
all, you need a chair.
Because, oh, if we go back
to Sonia Lupien, yeah.
I love her, she's just a genius.
She says, "The four methods
of emergency stress relief
are these, laughing,
singing, deep breathing,
and vigorous exercise" right?
Well, laughing and singing probably
aren't too available too during the test,
maybe beforehand, vigorous exercise,
for sure you can do this.
In Paul Tuff's book, he has
a whole chapter about me.
I won't go into long story,
but basically showing up in this girl's,
going to her house and
doing SoulCycle with them.
It's a wack-a-doodle story
at like 6:30 in the morning of an ACT.
It's bonkers.
And to blow off the cortisol,
super academic, super time mnemonic.
I couldn't get her sleep more.
And just, she sort of gassed
herself for 20 minutes,
took a shower.
I went away and got the score
because too much cortisol.
She was just on the wrong
side of that bell curve.
And then the deep
breathing is a big thing.
People probably know the box breathing
that the Navy seals created.
I mean, these are people
who have, you know,
probably high intensity
performance anxiety, right?
And deep breathing
purges cortisol out of our nervous system
and brings it back to normal.
I mean, pre-COVID, I was
still taking the SAT,
shoulder to shoulder with teenagers.
And, you know, just to
know what it feels like,
and I can sit there if my
pulse is still going like crazy
because I'm an old guy in
a room full of teenagers,
like that's weird, right?
But I wanna know what it feels like.
And I sit there when I'm
filling in my address,
I do deep breathing and
it brings me back down.
I'm not all tranquillo,
but I'm in this place where
I'm amped up but not crazy.
So again, I think of input in testing,
do they really know the stuff?
Look up at "Make It Stick" it's wonderful.
But then if you really know
that you learned it well,
then we start thinking about
these aspects of performance
and it may be a little bit
of A and a little bit of B.
- Great, great.
We are just about out of time.
I do want you, as you
say, in your new book,
you provide lots of
scripts and things to ask.
Let me ask you this
question that comes up a lot
when talking to parents,
how do I ask something
that gets my kids to say,
give me an answer other than fine.
When I say, "How are you doing?"
"Fine."
"How was school today?"
How can we get kids to
express their emotions?
- Yeah, I mean, oh, golly.
I mean, first of all,
it's probably helped for
us to remind ourselves
that teenagers, especially,
part of their work to become adults
is to individuate from mom and dad, right?
So they're supposed to push away from us
a little bit, right?
And so, they run away
and then they come back,
and run away, come back.
I mean, a few thoughts,
the first is for the love of P,
please ask them about
things other than school,
because so many kids feel like, you know,
there's an article I'm
still wanting to get
some paper that we basically had us,
hmm, let's take her,
how was school?
How are your grades?
Where are you applying to college?
Do you have a boyfriend, a girlfriend?
As though that's the sum total
of their experience, right?
So if you're getting
the fine, stop asking,
and stop asking about school.
Okay, but I have a specific to do now.
I'll come back then a moment.
Ask about kind of everything else,
particularly asking about their hobbies.
What are they interested in?
You know, politics,
everything else in the world.
Also, if you have a kid where there's,
you know there's a problem,
they don't have friends at school, right,
they're having a hard time.
Math is a hard thing.
When we keep asking about
the thing, that's a problem,
we're kind of interviewing for pain.
We're looking, and because in many ways,
what parents I think are trying to do
is they really just wanna
be told that it's okay,
so they don't have to worry about this.
But in this situation,
you're being the opposite
or non-anxious presence.
You're feeling like I have to
check over and over and over
and make sure that went out, okay,
just like, did you do homework,
did you do your homework,
did you do your homework, did
you do your homework, right?
It's putting all the
energy into that, right?
What was for lunch today?
What was the weirdest thing that happened?
What's going on?
I mean, particularly with
the last two years of COVID,
taking an interest in what
your kids are watching
at TikTok, right?
If you want your kids to be open with you,
try to ask them about things
other than they give you information
and they feel like they're
gonna be in trouble
or they're gonna be criticized for it.
- I love, what's the
weirdest thing you saw today?
That's fun.
- Yeah.
And if it is something that in school,
what was the hardest thing
that popped up in chemistry?
What was the dopiest thing?
You try to make those
questions a lot more specific
because, yeah, if you ask how was school?
Of course they're gonna say, fine,
because if they say,
well, it was really hard,
they feel like they're
gonna be interviewed
or grilled about the thing.
What, what, wait a second.
What do you mean you
didn't do all of this?
They don't wanna hear about this
because this is really interesting to me,
in writing this book,
we realized that one of the things is that
a lot of kids don't want to
share the hard parts of school,
life, friendships with their parents,
because they don't wanna
burden their parents.
They don't wanna get the parents upset
and it's too much for them to deal
with their parents' intense feelings
on top of their hard feelings.
So this is where kids say, fine,
even though we know it's not fine.
So I will share this
particular piece of advice
if you have a kid where you
know things are not fine,
but you can't get them to talk to you.
So I have a daughter who's
a senior in high school
and she is a complicated bird,
she's brilliant, 30 IQ points I've got,
has had her share of dark things.
This last couple years
have not been easy for her.
And when she is unhappy,
she just closes down, you know,
she's the kid in the cave.
And so the conversation
will often look like they,
"Hey, kid, are you okay?"
So she shrugs her shoulders, I'm like,
"Any I can help with?"
And I'll ask two or
three questions like that
and she's not giving it up.
And in many ways, these are her feelings
and these are hers to feel.
It's not my responsibility.
And I know that sounds
like a talent thing to do.
But honestly,
it's an important thing
for young people to learn
to be able to talk themselves
out of hard feelings,
if she can only get back
to baseline because of me,
I'm not doing my job as a dad.
So what I've done with her is this,
is validate and then offer support, right?
And then step away and
say, "well, sweetheart,
it sure looks like you had a day of it
'cause I don't know what's going on,
but you look really upset.
If there's any way that I can help,
please know, if you wanna
listen, if you want it,
whatever I can do to help" right?
"Is that okay?"
Shoulder shrug.
Here's the question that I ask,
"Is it all right if I circle
back in about half an hour,
just to check in and make
sure you're doing okay?"
Get the head nod.
And I swear, every time I've done this,
if I say, I'll be back in a half an hour,
in 20 minutes she's bounced downstairs.
So I say, I'll come back an hour.
She comes down in 40 minutes.
Every single time.
And she's just, and whatever cloud it is
that's been in her mind has just passed,
and not once have I found
out what she was upset about.
I knew she was upset.
She knew she was upset,
but she just didn't wanna share.
And so this is the way
we as parents kind of,
we offer support, we offer help for,
could a lot of times for kids to know
that we're there to help,
even if they don't take us
up on the help is helpful.
- Thank you.
I'm gonna close on that.
That seems like,
that's an excellent
note for us to leave on.
Thank you so much for joining us today.
Really appreciated all
the information you shared
and look forward to
diving into the new book.
- I hope you enjoy it.
I really appreciate.
Again, I love that you,
I love that the Khan Academy is taking all
of that kind of technical
stuff you teach everything
and really trying to broaden
it with some of the folks
that I'm grateful to be among those.
So thank you.
- Absolutely.
Thanks all for watching today.
We'll see you next time.